- DailyVee's gonna be
different on the weekends.
It's a whole different grind.
(tape rewinding)
(triumphant rock music)
What if I told you
this was the last Monday
morning of your life?
Hey guys, so it's a
Saturday morning.
This is Justin Novello.
- 'Sup?
- My amazing brother-in-law.
We're going to the church sale.
There's a local church by
my parents house where they
basically sell stuff.
It's kind of like a
thrift store so we're going,
we're gonna find stuff.
DailyVee's gonna be
different on the weekends.
It's a whole different grind.
Especially since I'm, obviously
a lot of you guys know that I'm
not going to share
as much family stuff so
I'm gonna have to be clever.
And we're going to go try to
be clever and make some flips.
Show you guys some action.
See you in a sec.
So this has been a little spot
that me and AJ have gone to for
years and Justin and
always some good deals.
You know, obviously I've talked
a lot about the garage sale and
the yard sales and the
town sales for a lot of you.
I don't know if a lot of you
been seeing but there's been so
many comments of people
flipping and making money.
So that's excited
me tremendously.
The other place that
I think a lot of people are
doing extremely well
with is thrift stores.
So obviously there's Goodwill
and all these national places
but my parents obviously,
as you can tell probably with
the background live in
rural New Jersey.
There are some of
these little spots where
you can make some great flips.
I remember AJ once found a
Donkey Kong Country
Super Nintendo game in package
and went for like $150 for like
$0.25 in this place.
While I've got you here, while
we're driving also talk about
some of the trends in the
business world that
you guys are
paying attention to.
I think on the weekends I'll be
able to take advantage of maybe
doing some
#AskGaryVee type stuff.
Things of that nature so
couple things that are really
interesting to me is watching
Instagram create features that
are absolutely
attacking Snapchat.
Basically now having all
the feature capabilities that
Snapchat has but on top of that
some of the functionalities that
direct marketers love.
A lot of you that follow me,
if you go to my stories,
you see that I'm using the swipe
up feature as a verified user
and a beta tester of this,
the conversion rates have been
phenomenal because at the end
of the day like I've always said
it's all about attention.
You know, I've always loved when
people misunderstood what to do
on Instagram and Snapchat
because they weren't
direct link places.
They weren't places
where you would click
and make a conversion.
You can say this is
how I'm converting.
They were trying to use historic
web dynamics against
these new platforms.
I kept saying look,
treat it like print,
treat it like television.
There's branding capabilities
but the part that wasn't talked
about was when some of
these branding and marketing
platforms, and what I mean by
that is they don't have direct
correlation to sales because
it's like a billboard or
a print ad or a TV ad.
You don't click your TV ad,
you don't click the billboard,
you become aware of a brand
and then you go and buy it.
That's branding and marketing
versus the sales tactic that so
many of you care about,
email conversion,
Google AdWords, Facebook ads.
It's only transactional.
You're not thinking in
the marketing level,
you're thinking in
the sales level.
That's why Snapchat and
Instagram were great for me.
They were incredibly smart
marketing platforms but what's
interesting now, and this is
something that all of you have
to keep in mind with marketing
platforms that are digital they
always have the ability to
convert to sales functionality.
So now, Instagram if you have a
big audience and you go into a
story environment and you swipe
up and it sends you to a direct
link if you're wearing a
T-shirt and you're like,
"Get this T-shirt on my website
right now," and you swipe up and
you go right to the landing
page and you're converting,
that's a whole different
ballgame and so watching the
branding and marketing platforms
of the social age start adding
sales capabilities, 'cause
Snapchat's coming out this
as well very shortly, is a very
powerful thing that's gonna make a
lot of you that are more sales
driven really start focusing on
these branding platforms.
So you're gonna have to start
thinking like a media company
and a content producer, not just
like a salesman to have that
complete 360 capability in
the mobile modern environment.
I got the first-person action.
Yeah, you're gonna get some
first-person action now.
I'm a big fan of
mugs by the way.
I've always thought that mugs
were underpriced on the 'Bay.
As you can see, it's
actually pretty busy here.
More than normal.
There are the stuffed animals.
Got my eye on that Mickey.
(light music)
Lots of books.
One of the categories I need
to figure out more
is playing cards.
Playing cards.
Anybody have any of these
chachkas in their house?
- They let me take
up negotiation.
- [Gary] What do you think,
Just? Doing good?
- [Justin] I think
this is really good.
Slim pickings in here and
you found some stuff,
that's for sure.
- [Gary] You finding anything?
- I am not.
- [Gary] Oh-for-life?
- No, no.
- [Gary] (laughs)
Oh-for-church sale.
Just, show yours.
12 bucks.
- [Justin] This is legit though.
- [Gary] Little Mermaid
that's like $15, $20.
- [Justin] Holy moly.
- [Gary] This is where
I need to get better with books.
I bet you this Vietnam
Experience set is like
worth real money and
I'm just like, "What is it?"
- [Justin] Yeah.
- [Gary] Look
what I looked up.
- [Cashier] We don't
have a plastic bag
but we have two of these.
- [Gary] Ten for everything.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You have
a great holiday, okay?
- You too!
- [Gary] Alright,
so we did good.
This set of books
is like a 30 spot.
This is like 15.
Just, I would say we spent
10 and made close to 100.
- Maybe more.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Yeah. Easily.
- [Gary] Not too bad.
- Yeah, yeah.
That was all you.
- [Gary] It's all you, baby.
The hustle, the hustle is real.
- The hustle is real.
- So this is how
Saturday DailyVees
are gonna go down.
The books easily like
30, (bell dings) maybe more,
I think we go for $49.99.
It's the holidays
we can flip it.
Ariel is gonna go for
15 (bell dings) easily.
This I think is 10, Just.
This is an original Care Bear.
I'm gonna look it up.
Probably 7 to 10,
we'll go 9.99 minimum so
we'll get 10 for that.
I haven't looked this up
yet but this is old as shit.
Old kangaroo vintage, yeah
I can't wait to look it up.
Looking up shit is, I sometimes
hold off 'cause like it's like
holding off, it's like
foreplay of thrifting for me.
- [Justin] This is really old.
- Yeah, this is pretty good.
This is gonna work.
This is some
Nickelodeon shit, 2001.
I know this guy is going to go
for 10 at least. (bell dings)
This is Ugly Dolls, this will
go for 10 at least as well.
Haven't looked up
this one either.
Wildlife, World Wildlife and
I got to remember it's not
Lala-Lucy it's Wow Wow
Wubbzy or something like that.
- [Justin] Yeah.
(bell dings)
- So, if we go 10,
10, 10, 10, that's 40,
50, 60, 70, 85
and the books, 125,
eBay fees, this, that, the
other thing we spent 10.
It's gonna be 10 for 110.
We're gonna make $100
profit for our 30 minutes here.
Plus, we had fun.
- It's a lot of fun.
- Brother-in-law fun.
- It's always fun.
- And, that's how we do it.
And you can, too, if you
just want it bad enough.
And for a lot of people
$100 extra in a week,
we're gonna go
post this now, too.
- Yeah.
- Hustle.
(light music)